you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest comm
the tactics trainer I'm going to try
three more puzzles and like before
before I go ahead and share my thoughts
feel free to pause the video so let's
get going
and I actually I'm going to do something
slightly different compared to the
previous videos namely I'm going to
spend I'm gonna at least try to not
spend no more than three minutes in
trying to solve each of these three
puzzles so let's hop right to it
it's white to move and my queen is
clearly being attacked doing a quick
material count I'm up material full
minor piece actually a minor piece and
upon but I like still needs to castle so
I don't let's see I wonder what we're
supposed to do here where my first
thought is where to move the Queen so
where's a good spot and I need to be
careful about where I move the Queen
because queen here could be annoying so
I want what I'm trying to do here is
find a way to address the threat on my
Queen and at the same time still keep a
close eye on c3 I don't think white is
needing to do too too much actually you
know what there's a secondary square I'm
seeing this one as well the ideas of
taking on b4 or playing to c3 could be
quite annoying like it for example Queen
b6 this is trouble there check here
check here take a look stuff like that
so is there a way to meet the threat
against my queen and still watch over b4
and c3 I could do that by playing here
going to see for my first thought was to
play here and attack the bishop but as
soon as I saw I needed to do something
about b4 as well I started to rethink so
I'm thinking Queen to c4 that's my first
candidate move I spent almost two
minutes so far so just about another
minute before I see what the solution is
whether or not I'm
let's see ah Queen c4 this is there more
forcing move not really I can't take the
brook is there a counter-attacking move
against the Queen that's not really
working
is it more retreating move might be
sneaky there might actually be something
to that Bishop c1 oh my goodness that
might be it
okay two and a half minute mark Bishop
c1 if Queen take if rip takes Queen
Bishop takes Queen I'm still on the rook
Wow
that might actually be it because Bishop
c1 where does the Queen even go if she
goes back here fine I take the Queen and
then I complete development I'm up still
up that minor piece so having a queen
trait is the same as what the same is
basically winning I think it's actually
Bishop c1 I started a little late I'm
gonna give myself a few more seconds
here I think it is actually Bishop c1
instead of just playing this quiet move
hoping there's not going to be anything
great black could do this is more
forcing retreating move I think I'm
gonna go with that it seems right
let's go for it yes those are cheating
moves they're not the easiest ones to
see I'm glad I found that so we're still
going on this is not the end of the
puzzle so okay um Queen takes Queen yeah
why not Queen takes Queen Knight takes
and then Bishop back here I have to be a
little bit careful cuz it potentially
made on d1 and I believe if you just
take the Queen let me just make sure
Queen takes Queen Knight takes Queen
takes Queen Knight takes is hitting the
bishop I would have Bishop to e2 saving
my bishop and defending against the main
threat on d1 and if rook to e8 I could
always have Bishop to e3 interfering
and the pressure on e2 I think he could
just take the Queen I don't see any big
problem with that to take the Queen yes
that was it
yeah it probably should have went a
little bit further in my I guess like
after Knight takes it is on the bishop
and it is threatening made on d1 I think
the follow-up of Bishop to e2 would save
the day and keep that extra piece
all right let's hop to the next one
puzzle do and it's an endgame puzzle so
all right
apparently there's a way to win this one
huh interesting okay white to move hmm
well there's two unprotected pieces here
both bishops are unprotected is there a
way to get here and skewer and pin pin
pin and then win the bishop not really
seeing that since the bishop is watching
over c6 there's something more for
example this bishop right here is kind
of running out of squares is he not he
is
for example rook g1 bishop here rook h1
pin and win that's nice what more might
there be actually after rook g1 Bishop
f3 and then maybe I'm stuck for a second
I'm giving some thought to rook c2 but
there's always a check take this bishop
and then Bishop versus rook the radical
draw that won't be the solution hmm what
other candidate moves might I have here
and notice I'm looking at these two
right here rook moves the forcing moves
I believe it what the first move will be
a rook move the question is which Square
rook g1 or rook to c2 probably probably
rook g1 like I was saying rook c2 bishop
f1
so this is my first thought I don't know
that I'm really gonna come up with
something better there's a first move
here Brooke g1 rook g1 Bishop f3 here
here's something I could I could see
here if I have two rook g1 if the bishop
plays here I think a strong move might
be Bishop to f7 threatening rook g6
planting the rook on the sixth rank
where all three black pieces would be
but there's clearly some other choices
for the bishop after rook g1 mm-hmm
there's f3 there's b7 there's a 8
there's a lot of different moves and I
don't know I don't know the exact
responses if it's making use of f3 be
seven and a eight I don't even know if
playing here with rook with Bishop f7 to
follow is a good plan I'm almost at the
three minute mark I'm not even sure is
there something really better than rook
to g1 I'm not seeing it if there is
something better
mm-hm yeah I'm just not seeing it I'm
gonna give it a shot hmm I said three
minutes per puzzle but it's actually
turning out to be much more that is the
first move
yeah I'm not calculating these through
to its end for sure so just step by step
I'm really at most thinking maybe one or
two moves ahead doing it in this manner
but running forward with this puzzle
from this point
Bishop f3 yeah again I don't even know
what I would do if the bishop played
here here but let's just take it as it
is Bishop is now on f3
so what springs to mind is King here and
then actually I could shut that idea
down right away because Bishop c5 gun is
the rook
so no King III move
what about Bishop here might be
something to that you know I think there
is something to that yeah
Bishop to f7 I think might be the one if
Bishop if Bishop h5 there's the the pin
and then you win the bisshop so Bishop
here is threatening this what if this
Bishop just moved somewhere and stops
the whole fork trick like Bishop here
Bishop f7 let's say Bishop f8 hmm or
Bishop here anywhere somewhere off of
this sixth rank there's something better
than Bishop to f7 King here again this
no thanks rook here oh geez how'd I miss
that okay I get it now rook f1 the
bishop moves and you hit the hit black
with the fork yeah that's what it is
isn't it oh I know what I would do if
the bishop played here here as well now
that's broken its rook f1 followed up
with the fork that's the solution
there's a check this puzzle still going
in and that would be the end of it
but what I was going to say is that
after that initial move after rook g1
Bishop f3 if the bishop went here here
you come over to whatever file it was on
right and then with the idea of point
also playing to the sixth rank so my
king is in check and now I have to find
a good spot for the King such as King to
d4 or where ya just king here no I have
to be careful King here you see I want
to be able to go first clearly get out
of check but after I move my king I want
to make sure
that there's not gonna be any dogs
barking no after king d4 there's Bishop
to a three with an ID of a skewer so if
I'm thinking about after King D for two
then attack this pinned piece
I'm sadly mistaken King D for Bishop a3
Bishop b2 check and I am I'm in some
trouble here so I think I need to dodge
this check and stay on a light square
how about here kingi - that seems like a
nice one kingi to stay on a light square
that's the only safe light square so
that this Bishop can't move and do
anything dangerous to my King so after
King e2 the bishop can move and attack
my rook but I could move my rook out of
the way and counter-attack that Bishop
and then finally I will be in a position
to play Bishop d3 and pick up this
pinned piece I think that that's it
let's go with King e2 that is it and
then this and then finally finally this
was a very sophisticated problem but
just going back to that initial position
if the oops this was the initial
position after rook g1 I was saying I
didn't know what I would do if the
bishop played let's say here here I
think if it goes to be seven or eight
you have a similar idea
just like when it played here to be rook
F one willful played to b7 you go to be
one if it goes to a eight you go to a
one and if it went to c6 I think it
might actually be Bishop to f7 however
I'm not a hundred percent sure on that
one
Oh or or maybe or maybe just coming over
somewhere here threatening to get on
this file winning one of the bishops
that's maybe the the one that's
trickiest for me to figure out but let's
let's uh let's dive into this last
puzzle so this was apparently the
solution to this one okay last problem
problem three of three let's see if I
could go for three for three here
black to move hmm all righty what about
rook check I'm clearly not the only one
who's thinking about rook check first
this rook is not protected there's a way
to take advantage of that I don't think
so
I'm gonna look at these moves first
check boom
there's also another check okay so the
rook check King age to g3 check huh
let's see okay rook check King to h2 the
king is also now on a diagonal and so
that could be important that could
definitely be important because as soon
as the replace check-in King plays here
this Queen is now restricted in some
sense because if she is to go off of
this diagonal there may very well be a
queen check on c7 picking up the rook on
d8 so taking into account this rook
being unprotected there might this might
be helpful here so I'm about a minute in
we're up to f1 check king h2 and then
after g3 check if the Queen takes the
pawn I could also be taking this pawn
with check queen h3 then there's Queen
to e5 check and if the Queen comes here
to block there would be rook to h1
deflecting the King away from defense of
the Queen on g3 I think this is it rook
check King H to g3 check now I only went
with the variation where the Queen takes
but if the King takes my first thought
is give a check on f2 and if the King
goes to the H file you give a check on
8th
one if he stays if he goes to g4 you're
picking up this pawn if the Queen blocks
there's Queen takes pawn here I believe
that this is it oh I believe I'm wrong
I'm probably not the only one who's
wrong
ouch that was painful what's the first
move Oh deadly quiet move I bet are you
kidding me man are you sure this
wouldn't work let's see I'm pretty sure
that's it then
I didn't even spend the three minutes I
was I was trigger-happy there I pulled
that move off too quick yeah one silent
but deadly move how do you stop me the
answer is you don't man yeah I guess
this turns out to be more forcing
because after Queen takes here you end
up having the variation I was citing I
would have only if I would have only
switched those moves I believe they're
gonna show Queen takes pawn and now
we're gonna have that little deflection
trick coming up so do I get any half
credit probably not so this is as far as
it's taking it and after Queen here
there would be a check and then after a
queen block let me see if I could
actually bring that up but they have an
analysis board here oops let me just
resize it here there we go I believe you
should be seeing it pretty good right
now
just like that nope not quite yet
just like that just have to resize this
window there we go
so you can actually play through it a
little bit these little VCR controls so
after this
oops oh the the computer move was this
and then it was black to move so after
this this is what I was talking about
Queen takes rook check King here Queen
takes pawn the Queen blocks check here
and if the Queen plays here there's this
month tactic of deflection and the other
variation that I didn't touch on at all
was that at this point after g3 well
there would be a check and then after
block he get
the Queen like this so I wonder if
actually giving check initially is still
working what else am I missing maybe you
could help me out those of you that are
viewing this video right now but maybe
well this is this I believe is the best
continuation but I wonder if there's
maybe half credit available for giving
check first and then following up like
this maybe not I don't know there's
still there certainly so many more
options for white at this point so fewer
options you usually it'll be the case
that white will have fewer options I
have to give a check but when you're
getting to this point right here
seems like white is now going to have
many different options whereas if you
make that initial silent move well you
pretty much better take that pawn
because with rook coming here to give me
well you got to stop that right away
don't you yeah this turns out that
silent move I guess as a result turned
out to be much more forcing believe it
or not alright
so two for three I'll take it feel free
to share how you did with these three
and I will catch you in the next video
that's all for now
take care bye
you